und er bewegt sich auf der
fraktionsebene erhard was haben denn die
fraktionsspitzen in dieser woche für
themen ausgemacht
die sind ganz nah dran an dem was sie
eben claudia d wie es auch berichtet
haben nämlich das treffen von olaf
scholz bei wladimir putin in russland in
moskau spielt ja eine ganz große rolle
natürlich in verbindung mit dem konflikt
zwischen russland und der ukraine das
haben wir in allen statements wie
bislang haben aufzeichnen können
durchaus schon gehört und der andere
große und wichtige punkt das ist die
morgige bund länder runde wurde ja die
ministerpräsidentinnen mit der
bundesregierung beziehungsweise mit
vertretern der bundesregierung zusammen
kommen um zu schauen wie kann können
weitere oder erste lockerungsschritte
aussehen um aus den corona maßnahmen
herauszukommen viele virologen viele
mediziner sagen die voraussetzungen
erste lockerungen vorzunehmen sind gar
nicht so schlecht aber es ist vorsicht
geboten und das hört man auch bei dem
einen und anderen hier in den
stellungnahmen vor den heutigen
fraktionssitzungen immer wieder heraus
da gibt es durchaus unterschiedliche
schwerpunkte oder schwerpunktsetzung wie
diese vorsicht denn aussehen könnte aber
in der regel nichts bleibt unterm strich
und in der summe natürlich der punkt
dass hier alle sich durchaus für da wo
immer es möglich ist lockerungen
ausgesprochen haben das gilt genauso für
die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen die
partei hat ja seit gestern nun auch
amtlich eine neue spitze mit den beiden
vorsitzenden ricarda lang omid nouripour
und der bundesgeschäftsführerin emily
büning die sind zwar schon ende januar
gewählt worden bei einem digitalen
parteitag aber seit gestern ist es wie
gesagt nun auch amtlich das digitale
votum ist noch einmal durch eine
briefwahl bestätigt worden und mit dem
überraschenden ergebnis dass omid
nouripour gleich mal neun prozent mehr
bekommen hat in dieser schriftlichen
abstimmung als bei der digitalen wie
gesagt ende januar aber wer schon länger
im amt ist das sind die beiden
fraktionsvorsitzenden nämlich
hasselmann und katharina dröge und
katharina dröge hat sich heute mittag
den fragen der kolleginnen und kollegen
hergestellt
bundeskanzler scholz ist ja heute in
russland eingetroffen aus unserer sicht
ein eine enorm wichtige reise in
schwierigen zeiten wir beobachten seit
wochen dass russland truppen an der
ukrainischen grenze zusammen zieht über
100.000 soldaten panzer hubschrauber und
schiffe im schwarzen meer das ist eine
situation die extrem besorgniserregend
ist die durch die nachrichten vom
wochenende noch unsicherer noch
besorgniserregender geworden ist und es
ist deshalb oberstes ziel aller
diplomatischen bemühungen eine weitere
eskalation zu verhindern einen weiteren
angriff russlands auf die ukraine zu
verhindern wir als grüne
bundestagsfraktion unterstützen hier den
klaren kurs von außenministerin berbalk
und auch von kanzler scholz wir stehen
in enger seite in enger solidarität an
der seite der ukraine wir werden alles
diplomatisch mögliche tun um die
sicherheit der ukraine zu schützen und
zu gewährleisten dazu gehört auch dass
wir unmissverständlich deutlich gemacht
haben dass jede weitere verletzung der
territorialen integrität der ukraine
einen extrem hohen preis haben wird
sowohl wirtschaftlich als auch die
thematisch ein anderes thema mit dem wir
uns als ampelkoalition in dieser woche
beschäftigen werden sind natürlich die
maßnahmen zur eindämmung der korona
pandemie wir haben uns heute morgen auf
ebene der fraktionsvorsitzenden in der
ampel koalition darauf verständigt dass
wir eine erste lesung für die gruppen
anträge zur einführung einer impfpflicht
in der ersten märz woche stattfinden
lassen werden wir werden uns im märz
natürlich die zeit nehmen für eine
sorgfältige beratung dieser
gruppenanträge aber auf der anderen
seite auch sicherstellen dass diese
zügig zum abschluss gebracht werden ich
bin fest davon überzeugt dass es zu
einem positiven beschluss für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht kommen muss um
ausreichend vorbereitet zu sein auf eine
nächste welle im herbst auf einen schutz
unseres gesundheitssystems eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems zu
verhindern darüber hinaus wird am
mittwoch die konferenz der
ministerpräsidenten sich damit
beschäftigen wie man mit weiteren
maßnahmen zur eindämmung der kommune ab
um geht hier ist es aus unserer sicht
wichtig dass alle diskutierten
lockerungen mit augenmaß getroffen
werden und mit blick auf eine debatte um
die verlängerung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes möchte ich
ihnen sagen dass wir uns heute morgen
auf ebene der fraktionsvorsitzenden
darauf verständigt haben dass wir als
ampelkoalition das
infektionsschutzgesetz anpassen werden
über die details diskutieren wir gerade
in der koalition das dritte thema das
die menschen in diesem land mit
sicherheit zu recht bewegt sind die
steigenden preise die insbesondere
zurückzuführen sind auf die hohen kosten
für fossile energie und uns ist es
wichtig dass wir hier sehr kurzfristig
zu weiteren maßnahmen kommen die die
bürgerinnen und bürger gezielt entlasten
insbesondere diejenigen gezielt
entlasten die es am deutlichsten
brauchen und das sind die menschen mit
geringem einkommen
mittelfristig geht es darum die
abhängigkeit von fossilen zu reduzieren
dazu gehört ein ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien dazu gehören maßnahmen zur
steigerung von energieeffizienz
kurzfristig müssen sozial gerechte
maßnahmen zur entlastung getroffen
werden dazu gehört eine schnelle
einführung eines sofort zuschlags für
kinder aus familien mit geringen
einkommen
dazu gehört auch eine faire entlastung
der mieterin beim co2 preis für wärme
hier wollen wir die vermieter zeitnah in
die pflicht nehmen das sind aus unserer
sicht gute maßnahmen und das zu ergänzen
dass die koalition schon beschlossen hat
nämlich einen heizkostenzuschuss für
bezieherinnen mit wohngeld und darüber
hinaus ergänzen zur diskussion um die
vorzeitige finanzierung der eeg umlage
aus dem bundeshaushalt sind ungefähr
sechs monate vergangen seit die
bundeswehr aus afghanistan abgezogen ist
sind noch immer vielerorts kräfte vor
ort die da weg wollen was würden sie
sagen wird dann da tatsächlich alles
getan und alles mögliche dafür getan
dass man die jetzt wirklich
schnellstmöglich daraus bekommt also
berbalk hat ja schon im dezember ein
ganz klares signal an die menschen in
afghanistan gesendet mit der botschaft
wir haben euch nicht vergessen wir haben
euch im blick sie hat deswegen auch
einen aktionsplan
afghanistan vorgestellt und das
auswärtige amt arbeitet in
zusammenarbeit mit dem
verteidigungsministerium mit hochdruck
an diesen fragen
andré auer vom zdf ich habe zwei fragen
wenn sie erlauben die erste frage jetzt
kam gerade die meldung der bayerische
ministerpräsident hat heute schon eigene
regeln für sein bundesland erlassen es
wird ja immer wieder gesagt dass damit
signal dass morgen von der mpk ausgehen
soll sei einheitlichkeit das sei
besonders wichtig wieviel
einheitlichkeit ist denn da jetzt
überhaupt möglich
also meine vermutung ist dass markus
söder an einem nicht interessiert ist
und dass es einheitlichkeit ihm geht es
eigentlich nur um selbstdarstellung und
profilierung das zieht sich als roter
faden durch sein gesamtes corona
management das erklärt das chaos der
vergangenen wochen und ich kann nur an
markus söder appellieren eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist ein ort
der gemeinsamkeit die situation ist
weiterhin so ernst dass sich jeder dort
zusammen reißen sollte
katharina dröge war das ko vorsitzende
der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen und
wir bleiben in der ampelkoalition und
wenn sie sich fragen sollten warum wir
die beiden großen fraktionen im
deutschen bundestag noch nicht haben den
werden wir gleich sehr viel mehr raum
geben beispielsweise ralph brinkhaus der
hier gleich sein letztes statement
zumindest als fraktionsvorsitzender
abgeben wird aber zunächst schauen wir
auf die fdp deren vorsitzender christian
dürr hat sich hier am mittag auch
geäußert und hat auch noch mal frank
walter steinmeier gratuliert und auch
friedrich merz den ich eben schon
angesprochen habe der heute nachmittag
zum neuen vorsitzenden der cdu csu
fraktion gewählt werden wird schon mal
alles gute für diese wahl zumindest
gewünscht und ansonsten sich auch mit
den derzeit virulenten themen
beschäftigt die wir auch schon
angesprochen haben christian dürr
ich möchte drei punkte gerne ansprechen
das erste ist natürlich die aktuelle
corona lager wie erreichen
offensichtlich jetzt den scheitelpunkt
dieser pandemie erstmals seit dezember
haben wir sinkende inzidenz
glücklicherweise ist das
gesundheitssystem in deutschland nicht
länger überlastet das bestätigt ja auch
die deutsche krankenhausgesellschaft und
das sind sehr erfreuliche nachrichten
für uns ist der gradmesser auch für die
einschränkung des öffentlichen lebens
immer die belegung der kliniken und die
überlastung ist derzeit jedenfalls nicht
zu befürchten das freut uns sehr als
fraktion der freien demokraten dass
wissen sie haben wir immer darauf
hingearbeitet dass die maßnahmen nach
dem 19 märz auslaufen werden und
deswegen freuen wir uns jedenfalls ist
dass der aktuelle stand das nach der
beschlussvorlage für die morgige
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sich auch
diese vorschläge wiederfinden es freut
uns sehr dass offensichtlich auch die
mehrheit der bundesländer das so sieht
wir müssten natürlich in der
vergangenheit freiheits eingriffe in
kauf nehmen das ist keine frage aber
klar ist auch dass nach zwei jahren
pandemie wenn es wieder die möglichkeit
gibt zu öffnen diese möglichkeit auch
genutzt werden sollen deswegen will ich
ausdrücklich sagen das ziel muss immer
sein für alle beteiligten eine rückkehr
zur normalität die menschen in
deutschland haben sich in den letzten
zwei jahren sehr sehr diszipliniert
größtenteils sehr diszipliniert an die
auflagen gehalten und im umkehrschluss
ist es daneben auch die aufgabe der
politik dass einschränkung dann wenn sie
nicht mehr nötig sind auch
zurückgenommen werden freiheitsrechte
müssen das ist klar nicht gewährt werden
vom staat sondern sie sind
selbstverständlich damit am 19 märz das
war mir immer wichtig damit am 19 märz
nicht alles auf einen schlag weg fällt
sollte die mpk eben schrittweise
lockerung jetzt schon beschließen das
scheint der fall zu sein wir müssen die
morgige mpk noch abwarten aber wenn das
in die richtung geht würde mich das sehr
freuen als erstes sollen die kontakt
beschränkung offensichtlich gelockert
werden für geimpfte im privaten bereich
und der zugang zum einzelhandel
offensichtlich auch zweig ist das
stichwort das ist ja in vielen
bundesländern bereits mittlerweile auch
gefallen wenn dann in einem zweiten
schritt auch gerade bei der gastronomie
und in anderen bereichen lockerungen
sind dann ist glaube ich richtig dass
man hier langsam aus den maßnahmen
heraus kommt und dann nach dem 20 märz
entsprechend wieder zur normalität
zurückkehrt sollte der wunsch bestehen
die masken pflicht beispielsweise über
den zwanzigster märz hinaus zu
verlängern und ich sage an der stelle
nicht eine bundes verpflichtung sondern
dass wir rechtsgrundlagen infektions
gesetz
infektionsschutzgesetz dazu schaffen
dann sind wir dazu ausdrücklich bereit
deswegen werden wir über anpassungen
infektionsschutzgesetz mit den ampel
partnern reden und sind auch dazu
derzeit im gespräch ich sage auch in
aller kleid und deutlich weil diese
pandemie ist immer eine dynamische lag
sollte es in zukunft zu gefährlichen
virus varianten kommen oder zu einer
erneuten belastung der krankenhäuser ist
der deutsche bundestag jederzeit
handlungsfähig das heißt jeder zeit kann
er wieder zusammentreten und maßnahmen
beschließen die pandemie ist eine
dynamische situation und wir haben ja
bei der del tabelle bereits im dezember
wird gezeigt dass der bundestag auch
hier sehr schnell handlungsfähig ist den
zweiten punkt den ich ansprechen möchte
ist der konflikt zwischen russland und
der ukraine
wir schauen natürlich nach wie vor mit
sehr großer sorge nach osteuropa
deutschland steht hier gemeinsam mit
seinen westlichen partner partnern an
der seite der ukraine und wir werden mit
aller härte reagieren wenn es zu einem
russischen angriff kommt und ich bin
froh dass der bundesfinanzminister
christian endler gemeinsam mit seinen g7
partnern vereinbart hat die finanzielle
und wirtschaftliche stabilität der
ukraine zu sichern wladimir putin muss
klar sein dass der preis sehr hoch wäre
sollte russland die lage weiter
eskalieren dazu gehört auch ein
mögliches aus von nord stream 2 und der
dritte punkt den ich ansprechen möchte
ist das was die union diese woche in den
deutschen bundestag einbringt nämlich
die forderung einer sogenannten
energiepreis bremse ich habe offen
gestanden ein bisschen das gefühl dass
es ein wünsch dir was spiel der
opposition ist auf einmal wird von der
union all das gefordert was man trotz
einer guten normalen haushaltslage in
den sechzehn letzten 16 jahren nicht
umgesetzt hat als man in eigener
regierungsverantwortung war und ich habe
den eindruck dass sich die union hier
insbesondere in widersprüche verstrickt
einerseits wird ja gegen den
bundeshaushalt gegen den
nachtragshaushalt
2021 geklagt gleichzeitig gibt es
vorschläge mit kosten in milliarden-höhe
ohne überhaupt über finanzierungs
vorschläge an der stelle zu reden und
das würde bedeuten dass die
schuldenbremse weiterhin jahre lang
ausgesetzt würde dass es aus meiner
sicht unbedingt zu vermeiden
insbesondere dann wenn wir in
deutschland und europa in der eurozone
und höheren zinsen gegenüber sehen dann
sollte eine weitere verschuldung
vermieden werden allein die von der
union vorgeschlagen vorübergehende
senkung der mehrwertsteuer auf energie
kostet bis zu neun milliarden euro
jährlich und ich glaube auch schon die
alte koalition hat sehr schlechte
erfahrungen mit einer vorübergehenden
mehrwertsteuersenkung gemacht denn wenn
sie vorübergehend es heißt es auch dass
sie dann wieder ansteigen würde wenn das
ganze zu ende ist und das würde erneut
die inflation antreiben insofern aus
meiner sicht nicht das richtige
instrument und insofern wäre das problem
in wahrheit nur aufgeschoben und wir
bleiben als andere koalition als freie
demokraten bei unserem plan wir wollen
die eeg-umlage bis zum sommer abschaffen
dass das ziel darüber geben wer jetzt
gerade derzeit ja eine ampel das wissen
sie und es ward als freie demokraten in
meinen herzensanliegen dass die
eeg-umlage so schnell wie möglich
abgeschafft wird wenn wir die union an
der stelle an unserer seite wüssten dann
wären wir darüber sehr froh ist es dann
zu bewerten dass markus söder jetzt
eigentlich vor kraft eigentlich noch vor
dem morgigen tage
also markus söder
hat in den letzten wochen bewiesen das
ist weniger um die bekämpfung der korona
pandemie geht sondern es geht
offensichtlich eher um mediale
darstellung als bayerischer
ministerpräsident ich betrachte das
wirklich mit sorge da kann man das thema
einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht gleich
einführen die er markus söder zunächst
nicht umsetzen wollte heute argumentiert
er wieder anders ich habe mich mit
seinem generalsekretär in einer talkshow
im dezember darüber duelliert über die
frage welche einschränkungen wir haben
da wollte die csu faktisch deutschland
in ein loch down bringen und jetzt sagt
der r wechselt vom team vorsicht in das
team freiheit mir geht es dabei nicht um
teams sondern um verantwortungsbewusstes
handeln in der korona pandemie und ich
glaube das eigene mediale interesse muss
zurückstehen in dieser pandemie auch das
parteipolitische und die sorge ums land
muss nach vorne gebracht werden und da
muss ich ehrlich sagen ist herr söder
aber ich erwähne auch tobias hans an der
stelle zurzeit jedenfalls was die
verantwortung für die gesundheit
betrifft aus meiner sicht nicht auf der
richtigen spur
christian doerr der vorsitzende der
fdp-fraktion hier im deutschen bundestag
mit relativ klaren worten in richtung
markus söder dem bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten und auch an tobias
hans dem ministerpräsidenten des
saarlandes was lockerungsmaßnahmen
angeht die schon getroffen werden bevor
die bund länder runde morgen
zusammenkommen viele sind der meinung
dass eingeschlossen ist ein gemeinsames
vorgehen und vor allem ein abgestimmtes
vorgehen jetzt ein ganz entscheidender
und wichtiger punkt ist und wir kommen
ganz langsam beziehungsweise relativ
zügig zur ersten personalie dieses
heutigen tages wir sehen die letzte das
letzte presse statement von ralph
brinkhaus als vorsitzenden der cdu csu
fraktion heute nachmittag wird ja
gewählt in der fraktion von meiner seite
wir hatten haben wochenende eine sehr
gute bundesversammlung mit einer
außergewöhnlichen rede von unserem
bundespräsidenten frank walter
steinmeier er hat die richtung
vorgegeben also auch in russland ukraine
konflikt das war gut das war wichtig da
stellen wir uns hinter und natürlich
spielt das auch heute in der
fraktionssitzung eine rolle spielen auch
angesichts des besuches unseres
bundeskanzlers in russland und in moskau
das ist ein thema was uns bewegt ein
weiteres thema was uns bewegt ist immer
noch das thema corona ist das thema
impfpflicht auch darüber werden wir
heute in der fraktion ausführlich
diskutieren und wir werden uns
positionieren daneben ist es so dass die
ganz normale oppositionsarbeit auch
weiterläuft wir haben zehn anträge die
wir stellen da geht es um zinsen für
steuern da geht es um gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse
das heißt also die opposition läuft und
die oppositionsarbeit funktioniert für
mich ist das heute das letzte presse
statement als fraktionsvorsitzender ich
möchte mich bei ihnen allen ganz ganz
herzlich bedanken ich möchte mich bei
bildern zurück mein pressesprecher
bedanken für die zusammenarbeit und wir
werden uns an der einen oder anderen
stelle sicherlich wieder sehen vielen
dank wir haben eine frage frau schweizer
vom mitteldeutschen rundfunk bitte
gestatten sie mir die persönliche frage
wie sehr bewegt sie das auch dass sie
den fraktionsvorsitz abgeben müssen und
wo genau sehen sie ihre rolle hat ihm
friedrich merz darf vielleicht etwas in
aussicht gestellt also ich habe das
gerne gemacht ich habe das gerade um
gelebt also das war unglaublich schöne
und herausfordernde aufgabe gerade auch
in regierungszeiten in sehr schwierigen
zeiten mit der korona pandemie mit
schwierigen zeiten für die fraktion aber
wie gesagt es war auch eine gute zeit
und insofern gehe ich da ganz mit mir im
reinen und wo man weiterer weg hinführen
wird das wird man noch sehen
meine damen und herren herzlichen dank
für ihr interesse
[Musik]
ja das ging dann doch ein klein wenig
schneller vorüber als wir das gedacht
haben dass das sollte eine längere ein
längeres statement von ralph brinkhaus
werden würde damit habe ich ohnehin
nicht gerechnet aber das ist dann doch
so knapp ist kommt dann doch noch ein
klein wenig überraschend für uns wir
werden aber
seinen nachfolger bereits um 15 uhr 30
hier auch wiedersehen so ist es uns
zumindest angekündigt werden dann worden
dann wird nämlich friedrich merz hier
sein erstes statement als
wiedergewählter muss man ja sagen denn
er war es ja schon von 2000 bis 2002
vorsitzender der cdu/csu-fraktion hier
noch einmal eine stellungnahme abgeben
ob die dann so dramatisch länger wird
das war ich im moment ein klein wenig zu
bezweifeln könnten kurzen kurzer blick
noch einmal auf ralph brinkhaus im
september 2010 ist er gewählt worden zum
vorsitzenden der unionsfraktion und das
kam damals doch einigermaßen
überraschend für viele beobachter sie
hatten eigentlich gedacht dass sich
volker kauder durchsetzen würde der bis
dahin dieses amt innehatte aber es kamen
dann eben anders mittlerweile sind
einige durchaus ein wenig traurig in der
unions fraktion deren ralph brinkhaus
hat einiges bewegt sagen abgeordnete aus
dieser fraktion was die struktur und die
arbeitsweise der fraktion angeht unter
anderem yvonne mag was sagt das so bei
uns im podcast unter 3 hat sich sehr
lobend sehr positiv geäußert über die
arbeit von
ralph brinkhaus als
fraktionsvorsitzender unter anderem auch
weil der frauen sehr gefördert hat in
den vergangenen etwas mehr als oder fast
vier jahren als rechtlich gleich noch
mal richtig aus wie lange das dann
tatsächlich gewesen ist wir schauen auf
die spd fraktion deren vorsitzender rolf
mützenich hat sich vor wenigen minuten
schon geäußert und hat auch ähnlich wie
ralph brinkhaus eben übrigens noch
einmal bezug genommen auf die
bundesversammlung vom vergangenen
sonntag und auf die wahl von
frank-walter steinmeier die wiederwahl
von frank walter steinmeier auf mütze
nicht ja meine damen und herren
herzlichen dank für kommen vor unserer
fraktionssitzung
die erneut wieder digital stattfinden
wird mit den kolleginnen und kollegen
nach dem wir uns am wochenende alle in
präsenz begegnet sind zur wahl des
bundespräsidenten ich will hier noch mal
ausdrücklich betonen dass ich nicht nur
über das ergebnis zur wahl von
frank-walter steinmeier für seine zweite
amtszeit mich sehr gefreut habe sondern
auch der auffassung bin dass
vieles unter den corona bedingungen gut
gelungen ist dass wir uns gut geschützt
gefühlt haben aber auf der anderen seite
auch den notwendigen
verfassungsrechtlichen rahmen
hergestellt haben zum anderen stehen wir
vor einer sitzungswoche die auch wieder
spannend sein wird im hinblick auf
verschiedene
tagesordnungspunkte ich will aber auch
sagen wir werden nach zwei jahren hanau
auch diesem schrecklichen anschlag
gedenken aber auch den frauentag im
plenum des deutschen bundestages begehen
und natürlich auch über die situation
an der ukrainisch-russischen grenze und
andere hoch brisante politische fragen
debattieren und hier bin ich auch bei
dem ersten punkt den ich betonen möchte
dass gerade in diesen minuten in diesen
stunden
olaf scholz im kreml mit dem russischen
präsidenten einen erneuten versuch von
seiten jetzt deutschlands nachdem es
sowohl
der amerikanische präsident der
französische präsident der britische
premierminister gewesen ist auswege aus
dieser krise aufzuzeigen der diplomatie
einen vorrang zu geben und genau so
stelle ich mir das auch vor dass wir in
den nächsten stunden und tagen weiter in
alle diplomatischen maßnahmen möglich
machen die dazu beitragen zur
deeskalation zu kommen und wenn das
gelingt wäre ich auch so froh dass in
der deutschen debatte es endlich gelingt
auch gute ideen für die diplomatie
voranzutreiben und nicht alleine über
andere maßnahmen hierzu diskutieren die
sich entweder aus innenpolitischen
gründen ergeben oder weil man sich mehr
auf allein nur ein instrument beziehen
will zum anderen haben wir neben dem
plenum auch ein herausragendes
politisches ereignis das der mpk also
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die
sich ja und das unterstützen wir
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
vorgenommen hat auf der einen seite
berechtigterweise über
lockerungsmaßnahmen auch nicht nur zu
sprechen sondern sie dann auch auf den
weg zu bringen sind der festen
überzeugung dass das was wir den
bundesbürgern in den letzten wochen
gesagt haben dass wir nämlich große
vorsicht auch bestimmte verhaltensregeln
auch durchaus einschränkungen rechtliche
einschränkungen gegeben haben jetzt gut
auf einem weg sind die lockerungen auch
zu prüfen und auch zu gehen aber auf der
anderen seite auch weitere
schutzmaßnahmen vor zu halten und das
betrifft glaube ich dann auch den
beschluss der mpk wir werden nicht alle
maßnahmen fallen lassen können so dass
sich auch der festen überzeugung bin
dass das was am 19 märz nämlich
auslaufen wird das
infektionsschutzgesetz
zumindestens rechtlich weiter bestand
haben muss und darüber wird der deutsche
bundestag dann auch rechtzeitig
entscheiden
und auf der anderen seite werden wir uns
uns jetzt sind die gruppenanträge
zumindestens einen gruppenantrag heute
den abgeordneten übersandt worden dass
sie sich dem anschließen können nämlich
meiner fraktionskollegen dagmar schmidt
heike behrens und
dirk wiese die nämlich auf der einen
seite eine impfpflicht ab 18
vorgeschlagen haben und auf der anderen
seite auch glaube ich brücken gebaut
haben in andere bereiche hinein das
finde ich sehr gut ich bedauere das ist
offensichtlich andere nicht gelungen ist
rechtzeitig für diese sitzungswoche
gesetzentwürfe vorzulegen deswegen wird
es erst in der kommenden sitzungswoche
zu den zur ersten lesung von
verschiedenen gruppen anträgen kommen
aber ich bin mir ganz sicher dass wir
noch vor ostern hier abschließen werden
und zum schluss würde ich auch noch mal
gerne für meine fraktionen betonen dass
das was ich vor einiger zeit hier bei
einer pressekonferenz auch gesagt habe
weiterhin auf der tagesordnung steht vor
dem hintergrund hoher belastungen
insbesondere im energiebereich gehen wir
weiterhin davon aus dass diese koalition
auch in den nächsten tagen gemeinsam
vorschläge belastbare vorschläge
unterbreiten wird um auch die
bundesbürger hier in dieser frage
nachvollziehbar auch zu entlasten so
weit meine drei bemerkung vielen dank
schon einige fragen ist bei haring
das eine ist noch mal eine klarstellung
also das infektionsschutzgesetz muss
ihrer meinung nach vor dem 19 märz noch
einmal geändert werden um
sicherzustellen dass maßnahmen dann noch
weitergeführt werden können und sehen
sie eigentlich bei der fdp eher die
tendenz die diskussion über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht zu verschleppen
sie haben darauf hingewiesen dass der
eine antrag immer noch nicht vorliegt
der rinke in der tat glaube ich dass die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und die
länder nicht auf alle maßnahmen werden
verzichten wollen wir sehen
vorsichtig vielleicht eine ein rückgang
beim
infektionsgeschehen das hat was mit den
vorsichtsmaßnahmen zu tun das hat
insbesondere mit dem verhalten auf von
bundesbürgern zu tun die sich nicht nur
haben impfen lassen sondern die auch
weiterhin vorsicht walten lassen aber
auf der anderen seite wissen dass masken
tragen dass möglicherweise bestimmte
maßnahmen am arbeitsplatz oder an
anderer stelle vielleicht auch weiterhin
noch notwendig sind ich glaube auch dass
wir uns darauf einstellen müssen dass es
weiterhin auch hotspots geben wird auf
die die länder auch reagieren müssen
ohne dem beschluss der mpk vorgreifen zu
wollen kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen
dass die bundesländer dafür auch einen
rechtlichen rahmen
weiterhin erhalten wissen wollen und
dafür wird der deutsche bundestag auch
das entsprechende instrumentarien
infektionsschutzgesetz dann auch
gemeinsam
letztlich den ländern über antworten und
ob ich irgendwelche tendenzen bei
koalitionspartnern erkennen will das
bleibt mir überlassen wichtig ist
einfach dass wir gut in dieser koalition
zusammen wirken wollen zum schutz der
bevölkerung auf der einen seite aber
eben auch das möglich machen weil
niemand von uns leichtfertig
verfassungsrechtliche freiheiten gerne
einschränken wollte aber sie waren in
der pandemie notwendig gewesen
die zweite frage bezog sich auf die
allgemeine impfpflicht ob die fdp das
bewusst nicht vorliegt weil es ja sich
um gruppenanträge handelt treten hier
nicht die fraktion auf sondern einzelne
abgeordnete und ich habe einzelne
abgeordnete
doch sehr früh in der
bundesrepublikanischen diskussion erlebt
die schon wussten was sie auf den weg
bringen wollten und dass sie das bis
heute nicht schaffen damit müssen sie
selbst umgehen
ich habe eine frage zu afghanistan zur
evakuierung der ortskräfte des ist schon
ein halbes jahr her wie bewerten sie die
evakuieren und die lage dort nun ich
habe keine aktuellen informationen weiß
aber weiterhin dass es bisher nicht
gelungen ist alle die die ausreise
willig und letztlich auch dazu in der
lage sind aus dem land ausreisen konnten
bisher habe ich aber auf der anderen
seite auch den eindruck dass frau
berbalk das zu einem der schwerpunkte
ihrer arbeit im auswärtigen amt macht
und alles daran setzen wird auch
weiterhin kräfte hier nach deutschland
auch zu bringen unter erschwerten
bedingungen weil natürlich wir es mit
einer situation der taliban an der macht
auf der einen seite haben auch nur eine
geringe besetzung unserer dortigen
vertretung darauf zurückgreifen können
und auch nicht alle reisemöglichkeiten
so einfach haben aber weiterhin einen
großen schwerpunkt hier gesetzt wird
er wird vielleicht habe sie richtig
verstanden dass sie vom prinzip her
sagen mir ist es egal ob das
infektionsschutzgesetz jetzt so wie es
ist verlängert wird oder in abstimmung
mit den ländern in einer abgespeckten
variante das ist also diesen dass sie
offen sind für diesen diskussionsprozess
dass sie da noch nicht festgelegt sind
eigentlich was jetzt dann am ende noch
bestand haben soll und dann die zweite
frage sind sie noch optimistisch dass
man mit der union so eine art kompromiss
modell zur im schlecht entwickelt also
egal ist mir gar nichts sondern ich will
schon
gesetze auf den weg bringen die hand und
fuß haben die ich aber auch gerne in
unserem föderalen system mit den ländern
abgesprochen wissen will weil sie
natürlich dann letztlich auch für die
durchsetzung
mitverantwortlich sind zusammen mit den
kommunen deswegen möchte ich die
maßnahmen an die hand geben die die
länder für unverzichtbar auch in zukunft
halten um zumindestens das was an
erfahrungen an vorsicht an bestimmten
maßnahmen auch notwendig gewesen ist um
diese pandemie einzugrenzen dass auch
weiterhin rechtlich zu ermöglichen
und ich bin durchaus sonst hätte ich
nicht als angebot gegenüber der
opposition gegenüber der union gemacht
sehr zuversichtlich dass ich
abgeordneten weiterhin anbieten will in
einer durchaus dem gewissen zu
verantwortenden frage nämlich der
allgemeine impfpflicht alles auch zu
eröffnen das sich auch unions
abgeordnete daran beteiligen und ich
will weiter nicht davon ablassen auch
dann mit dem zukünftigen
oppositionsführer mit herrn merz dazu
auch ins gespräch zu kommen selbst wenn
ich die etwas schroffer ablehnung
gestern auch zur kenntnis nehmen musste
ich habe eine frage von themen steffen
zeit online welche milden corona
schutzmaßnahmen sollten auch nach dem 19
dritter im infektionsschutzgesetz weiter
ermöglicht werden und wäre es zeitlich
denkbar dass im plenum im beschleunigten
verfahren in der nächsten sitzungswoche
im märz zu beschließen und ich habe ja
eben gesagt wir wollen den ländern im
zusammenwirken mit der bundesregierung
die maßnahmen weiter an die hand geben
die erforderlich sind jeder muss für
sich selbst beurteilen ob sie mit oder
streng sind aber wir wollen maßnahmen
rechtliche maßnahmen an die hand geben
und der deutsche bundestag hat bisher
immer gezeigt dass er
vor einer frist in der lage gewesen ist
gute gesetze auf den weg zu bringen